so when I leave a hotel I feel bad for
the house cleaner so I completely clean
everything up I put everything in a pile
I separate and I take off the sheets and
it was a huge urine stain
look at that not just not just a huge
urine stain that's really gross yeah I
will say
no way there's nothing redeeming about
this I called to the front desk and the
guy goes yes we know that we have this
problem we have mattress pads there on
order
we know that we have this brain know
that we have this problem
it's not just your room they're on
orders every mattress is pissed up yeah
and by the way it's crazy when I woke up
and or when I saw that I go I can't wait
to show you I thought of you oh thank
you
not you I got a joke I didn't often
think of me with excrement different
kinds